oh I think you're gonna take your
business elsewhere well lucky for you I
believe in second chances now I know
that you don't have girl baseball
trophies in stock but could you have one
made special sure great a custom mold is
50 bucks and it takes six weeks paying
you $50 for a trophy and I don't have
six weeks well does your daughter look
like a horse maybe she'd like this and
you all like God talk was covering
something really evil I'm trying to make
a special trophy for Missy so I'm gonna
take this head and put it on that body
whatever you say dr. Frankenstein my
daughter deserves to have a trophy that
looks something like her so this is kind
of a feminist gesture on your part I
prefer to think of it as a maternal
gesture let's just split the difference
and call it the stuff of nightmares
it'll look better when I paint it I
don't think so
[Applause]
hey I have something to show you what's
up I was gonna give this to you at the
end of the season party but I was so
excited that I wanted you to see it now
what the hell is that I couldn't find
any girl baseball trophies so I made you
one
eyes are head so big it's a Barbie head
I had to improvise you chopped the head
off one of my Barbies don't be silly I
bought a new one I could have had a new
Barbie the point is you deserve to be
recognized appropriately for everything
you've accomplished you can't give that
to me in front of all the boys why it's
embarrassing
well we have plenty of time I can make
the head smaller or the body bigger or
little bit mom I just want the same
trophy everyone else gets but I want you
to feel special and I just want to feel
regular okay well I'll make sure you get
a regular one at the party thank you
mom wait I get what you were trying to
do
it's nice buttocks can I keep that one
too you really want it I do
[Music]
despite her many flaws my sister did
have a soft spot in her heart
and fondness for blowing things up
[Music]